Feign madness,
but keep your balance hide
behind the mask of a fool,
a drunk or a mad man to create confusion
about your intentions and motivations.
Lower your opponent into underestimating
your ability until overcompensate
overconfident. He drops his
guard, then you may attack.
Yeah, that like the movie white
men can't jump your see that.
So he did it. Woody. Oh, I mean he
made it like he couldn't play ball.
Like he was just this Dork, Jeet,
what he call a chump, whatever.
That's what they'd call him
chump. Like he's Super Dorky.
He goes and everyone else is just so
cool and boom, flashy and all this stuff.
He comes in, he said he's
super nerdy and you know, boom.
Of course they pay a Kim, you know,
kind of thing. And then he beats him.
Would he beat them with flashiness or
would he beat them with, with traditional,
let's call it just who's your style?
Hardworking. Yeah. Basket. Well,
no, he had legitimate skill. He was
like this. So yeah, he'd come in,
he'd be Super Dorky. And then, um, he,
at first he tricked them. So he
came in the introduction to him,
he was like the acting all Dorky. And
then the guys, the Wesley snipes in them,
they're all playing
basketball in there, you know,
get into a little arguments or whatever.
One guy gets hurt where's Bunyan on and
off something and they're like, hey,
we need another guy. And then the guy
who's like, you know, let's, you know,
get him or whatever. So they're like,
ha ha ha. You know? Yeah, you got him.
Whatever they play, he ends up to
be pretty good, doesn't show a lot,
but he's like pretty solid. And then
they're like, yeah, you guys lucked out.
You had this Dorky guy, you guys kind
of lucked out. And he's like, Oh yeah,
you know, maybe you did look up
or maybe I'm just better than you.
But they're already convinced he's
the stork you got in there like cough,
I'm better than you. He's like, all
right, well let's bet kind of thing.
They're already convinced. Pool sharks
are scenario. Yeah, exactly right.
Same exact thing. Yeah. Yup.
That's pretty obvious one.
And I think,
I think one thing that again to take away
from this is if you know these things,
you're less likely to be suckered
in by them. Yeah, that's,
that's the most important thing. Yeah.
That you see the pool shark thing,
I saw a guy who really
clumsily tried to do that.
He'd worked in night club,
we had a pool table in there and this
guy came in and he like acts like he's
like, he comes in and just a normal guy,
he comes in with his own cue
by the way, his own pool stick,
which is an indicator like total giveaway.
And then he comes in and then immediately
when like he kind of enters the little
scene, you know,
the little area where he acts like
he's just kinda drunk and just real
oblivious, you know, he just total
just switches to a different guy.
And here's the thing, we, you can't let
drunk people walk around in the bar.
So you know, when waitresses or
other, or the manager would come by,
they'd be like, Hey, is that
guy that guy's do junk? Like,
why are you kind of like, keep an eye
him? And I'm like, he's not drunk.
He's like acting drunk. I go talk
to him just to sort of make sure,
and he's just like all normal talking
and then like, oh man. But yeah,
he tried no one. I mean, it wasn't
like normal to get money from he,
he wouldn't get money from anyone.
Well, here's the thing. No,
because it was like a nightclub.
It wasn't a competitive pool hall.
No one cares. No one's going to take
his, no one's even going to bet.
They're like, Bro, we're just
cruising. Like, why are you, you know,
wanting to be that kind of thing.
I'm not saying that happens,
but I'm saying that's the
attitude. In this day and age,
you'd have to be pretty dumb to fall
for this in a pool hall scenario.
Beat this guy. You gotta really think
you could beat him, right? Just be dumb.
All right, next.